I'm here to talk to you about a topic that sort of summarizes what we do in my lab.
That's sort of lumped together under
this title of The Mechanical Side of Artificial Intelligence.
So I'm going to start off with a few definitions first to get us on the same page.
And then I'm going to jump into, the best way I think I can describe our work is by example.
And so I'm just going to go through three examples from our work that I think highlights
the themes that I want to get across in this sort
of notion of the mechanical side of artificial intelligence.
So to start off,
let's start with a definition that you're probably familiar with,
which is the sort of maybe now classical side of artificial intelligence,
which is basically having computers, robots,
machines able to perform tasks,
which would normally involve the level of intelligence of a human.
So things in terms of perception,
autonomy control, that would normally require human intervention.
So this is a very old concept,
coined just down the streets at MIT.
So, that's not what we do,
so in my lab we do kind of the other side of this,
which again we call the mechanical side of artificial intelligence.
To contrast  this, this is developing new technologies,
new robot platforms specifically,
which make these questions of perception autonomy and control
easier by virtue of their mechanical design,
their material systems, their manufacturing strategies etc.
So we're really thinking about,
let's build new robots that can make these sort of higher order AI concepts.
Make those things easier.
So how do we do that? So, that's what I'm
going to talk about for the rest of this discussion.
Well one of the things I want to point your attention to,
is that this concept is not new.
In fact, I'll argue towards the end of this discussion that this is actually much,
much older than what we think about usually today, is artificial intelligence.
Okay. So, let's jump right in.
So I'm going to illustrate,
as I said through examples and the examples I'm going to give
are in these three categories: Robotic insects,
soft robotics in particular soft robotics for deep sea applications,
and then I'll talk about some more recent work in developing an entirely soft robot.
So let's jump right in. Robotic insects, what do I mean by this?
One good example of this,
is this device here which we call the RoboBee.
So this is a 80 milligram device which is supposed to mimic the key functions of bees.
And when I say this is relatively low level.
So just understanding flight behaviors,
understanding fluid mechanics being able to translate these into bio inspired designs.
Understanding how we can overcome obstacles in terms of,
how do we manufacture things at small scales?
How do we develop actuators that mimic
the muscle function and structure that we see in natural systems?
How do we understand what sensors and
sensor modalities we'd want to have for given tasks?
How do we understand new computational architectures that would really satisfy the size,
weight and power constraints imposed by such a system?
Then eventually on to power systems,
power storage energy distribution within this device.
Then finally thinking about having lots of
these things do interesting things in aggregate.
I'm not going to talk much about the application side.
Why would we do this?
The answer might be very sort of unsatisfying in the sense that,
the motivations from a sort of
task perspective or an application perspective are going to be basically the same thing,
that anybody that's developing an autonomous robot is going to tell you.
So basically, you put these things where you wouldn't want to put a human or an animal.
Tasks that are repetitive, dangerous,
whatever, that's where these things might find application.
Maybe you can go beyond,
what you might typically see with PackBots and Roombas and the like.
By thinking about these things is very small, very agile,
being able to get into nooks and crannies,
that you might not be able to get into otherwise,
maybe you can motivate things by having lots of distributed systems, distributed agents,
which could increase the effectiveness of coverage or efficiency of coverage,
graceful degradation of failure and maybe
these things can be made so cheap that they could be disposable.
But am I going to talk about all of that.
Really, what drives us,
what motivates us, is not those things.
It's really the technological exploration that has to come about,
if we want to really do this.
I will try to allude to this throughout,
but and this is something that's directly relevant to our role in this institute,
is we're constantly trying to figure out if we can solve some of these things.
If we can answer some of these questions.
Then what are those solutions good for outside of this context.
So, I'll try to allude to this throughout, but for example,
if we can resolve issues in micro fabrication and small scale actuation incensing.
Then maybe we can make small scale surgical devices.
Better and more effective, more dexterous,
more feedback to the surgeon and we're doing that as well.
As part of this project,
as I said, we have to answer all these questions.
The first question that we had was,
how can we build something at these scales?
On one end of the spectrum,
we have MEMS (micro electromechanical systems) and techniques that are derived from
the integrated circuit industry for the last five, six decades.
That provide us with a suite of tools on micrometres or sub- micrometre,
sort of size scales.
We don't really want to go that direction.
It fits the sort of need in terms of the scales that we're interested in,
but it limits us in other ways.
It limits us in terms of the suite of materials that we can use,
the sort of dimensionality of the structures we can build,
you know two and a half dimensional.
Maybe we can get out of,
more sort of surface and bulk micro machining processes,
but we really want to create
rich three dimensional objects with all sorts of degrees of freedom,
articulation etc., as you would have in the organisms that inspire some of this work.
Most importantly, which is a theme that will come
up over and over again in this discussion is,
if we want to be able to build these things,
we really don't understand them.
We really don't understand,
despite our best efforts and all the modeling that we could put on these things,
the best way we can understand these systems is by build and test,
build and test and often to failure.
So we really have to have a process which is,
a manufacturing strategy which is going to give us the ability to
manufacture things on the order of days.
Whereas more MEMS type processes might be on the order of months.
So that's may be the most important distinction here.
Okay, so that's one end of the spectrum.
On the other end of the spectrum,
I'm sort of illustrating the construction of an assembly of a internal combustion engine.
I don't want to operate in this regime either.
I don't want to be assembling thousands of
arbitrarily shaped components with
feature sizes ranging from micrometres to centimeter, under a microscope.
Consider this sort of the nuts and bolts approach to this.
So I don't want to do that for reasons of yield
and complexity and maybe this is sort of intuitive.
But I'm going to contradict myself,
because this is exactly how we started doing this.
Another way to describe this would be
the graduate student with tweezers manufacturing strategy,
which pissed off a lot of graduate students.
It is really not conducive to building things on this very sort of short time scale.
It takes a tremendous amount of skill.
This is basically one of my former graduate students that has a surgeon like skill,
and able to do this under a dissection microscope.
All of these pieces if you can tell are some millimetre or millimeter sort of range,
and there are complex objects.
It's not Lego type system where you can just sort of click things together.
So this has a lot of problems but really the main problem with this is,
if you were to do things in this way,
where it might take the most skilled students that I've had in
my lab in terms of sort of physical skill and spatial reasoning,
all this, it takes him
a few weeks to assemble something like this.
The problem is then these devices become precious and it doesn't really allow us
to explore the rich design space that we would otherwise really want to explore.
So, we set out to change this and explore new options.
So, this is, I think, really where one of
the first examples of this concept of mechanical intelligence.
How can we embody all of the motions that were
being conducted by that student as he assembled that device?
How can we embody them within
a composite structure and have this
all do all of these complex assembly procedures for us?
So for that, we took inspiration from two places,
the first was Nobel laureate Richard Feynman who back in the late 50s was
prophecizing the many aspects of micro robotics and micro machines in general,
talking about the economies of scale that you would get as you shrink down in size,
talking about small systems building other small systems,
building replicas of themselves.
So, tiny hands building robots,
and so that was one piece of inspiration that we had.
The other piece of inspiration was from my son
who at the time was very much into pop-up books.
So, you could think about pop-up books as being these, everybody is played with these,
these fantastically complicated structures that come about by very simple means,
very very simple actuation, if you will.
You unfold something, you push something,
you pull something and out pops,
these really fantastically complicated structures, right?
This gave rise to this assembly paradigm that we
call pop-up book MEMS which is illustrated here.
So, now we have this device which is sort of in the middle here,
you can kind of see what's happening is we have this sort of
device that we want and around it we have this thing we called
an assembly scaffold which is basically just a set of linkage mechanisms
which if I want to wing over here and
an actuator over here and a transmission mechanism over here,
then I can build those.
The articulation, the motion that is involved with linking those components by folding.
So, that's exactly what you're seeing here,
is what happens is we create this structure,
I'm not going to have time to go into all the details of how we do this,
but we basically take a bulk micro machining process where we take individual layers.
These individual layers can be anything,
they can be metal, ceramics,
polymers, composites, it doesn't really matter.
We use a non-contact direct right laser machining process to make patterns,
to make cuts on these individual layers of
relatively thin materials and then we stack these materials together,
create a laminated structure which is what you are seeing as the video progressed.
This structure then had many many layers, so 10, 20,
30, 40 layers of these constituent materials.
Within this, we can also make these parallel devices,
we can make mechanisms by folding.
So, that's a very simple concept but the implementation of it is basically,
if I have rigid materials surrounding a compliant material,
that compliant material then describes a fold,
describes a region, a weakened region,
that we can then array however we want throughout this device,
and then create these linkage mechanisms
which then can create arbitrary degrees of freedom.
So, I can get anything, think back to
the most complex pop-up book mechanism that you've ever seen, we can do that,
but we can do that now,
that arbitrary scales to very small,
even smaller than what I'm showing you,
to arbitrarily large if you'd want,
although there's better ways to do things the larger scales.
So, this has a number of nice features.
The features that this has are we can create anything,
any complex mechanism or device and this is not just hand way view,
we can actually prove this.
In fact, we work with some computational origamists at MIT Erik Demaine,
Daniela Rus who we spent a lot of time talking with about
these types of processes and it turns out
that it's provable that you can make any mechanism you want,
any structure or any mechanism you want,
by this process of folding.
So, that's one nice thing. Another nice thing I
already told you is that we can include any material you want.
One question that I often get is well why don't you
3D print these devices you want to make.
That's a good question.
Some of the challenges associated with scale aside,
3D printing techniques are typically limited in terms of the types of materials you
can have and the material diversity you can have within a given parts.
This is not so. So, we can have
any arbitrary material combination you want and in fact in the video,
you saw I didn't point it out but within
this layered structure are the muscles for this device.
So, we use piezoelectric actuators and they're buried within the layers of this device.
Related to that is these things,
you could be scratching your head and saying,
well you're basically just making
a multilayer printed circuit board then folding it and that's exactly what we were doing.
So, we can actually have circuits pattern
directly onto the surfaces of these things and create
complex electromechanical devices that
require no post assembly in their three dimensional shape.
Scale invariance, and so I think I hit all the highlights.
So, this allows us to build devices like this,
this is a few years old now but this particular design was quite successful.
The next challenge then was design,
I'm going to sort of gloss over this
because I don't have time to tell you the chronology of this,
it basically, with this process,
with these types of processes in hand,
now we can make devices like this in a matter of hours.
I'm exaggerating a little bit, but not really,
I mean it's a very quick process to be able to build
these types of devices and certainly a very minimal
manual labor or you can go back to the very manual if you want,
but we can build these things very quickly.
So, we've iterated over
dozens and dozens and dozens of generations of these types of
devices in trying to figure out how do we understand?
How do we move the wings through the air?
Do we just do biomimicry and try to recreate the types of
motions and types of morphologies that we see in natural systems in flying insects.
By the way, bees is just a metaphor,
it's supposed to invoke the social insect nature,
these are more like flies actually,
flies being the only order of insects which actually have two wings.
That was chosen partially for
their agility but also partially because two wings are easier than four.
So, then the question of design.
So how do we actually think about designing these systems?
This is a very simple device.
The way that it works is I cut the robot down the middle and I have
an actuator in either side and that actuator is
basically just a little artificial muscle that's doing this.
That very small motion is then mapped through a flexer based transmission mechanism,
it's just a gearbox without the gears,
because those wouldn't work and I'd be happy to tell you that offline.
Then that flap, that little motion then gets amplified into this large flapping motion.
Then the second, I think interesting sort
of connection to this concept is the mechanical side of artificial intelligence is,
that's a lot of passivity in this device.
So, when I started thinking about how do we build a device like this?
We worked with biologists and the biologist said, "Well,
you have two wings and each wing should do this sort of
flapping motion and this wing rotational motion."
So, I'm an ignorant roboticist, I just thought, "Okay,
well that means two degrees of freedom,
two actuators per wing."
But it turns out that's it's not a very efficient way to do this because as you're
actuating these devices and we happen to actuate
them at resonance for purposes of efficiency,
it turns out you have a two input,
two output system that you're operating,
at one of the resonate modes and it turns out you'd be going to be throwing away
energy into the other resonate mode if you do that.
So anyways, we actually use a lot of passive modes in these devices.
One of the passive modes is this rotation.
So, we actuate this motion and allow this to be passive and just tune,
this is mediated by a little flex of your hands,
your little fold at the base of the wing that you probably can't really see here.
By tuning the inertia of the wing,
the axis of rotation of the wing and the stiffness of this fracture,
we can get this quasi-static rotation modes
tuned to the appropriate phase relative to flapping to generate optimal lift.
It turns out after we did this, we realized,
we looked back at the biological literature and there's
a lot of evidence that flies do the exact same thing.
So, I'm not going to talk a lot about
that aspect which I just alluded to the fact that we can start to use
these bio inspired devices to reverse the error of
bio inspiration and start to use these things to tease
out biological hypotheses in ways that would be difficult with
the animal but that's an example perhaps of that.
So, this is illustrating what I just said about
the ability to individually address each wing.
So, then the way that this works, is I flapped these things and it's basically like
an amplitude modulation scheme with a cross product with the way a helicopter flies.
So, the way that that works is I can control,
I flap these things at resonance,
so I don't change the frequency of operation,
I just create bilaterally
asymmetric amplitude changes which
then if I have a fixed frequency and change the amplitude,
I'm changing the velocity of the wing,
the lift force generated goes as velocity squared roughly,
so then I can do force modulation independently on each wing to create body torques.
The way I do that is by,
if I have a larger amplitude on one side than the other,
then I have a larger force on one side than the other, so I do this, right?
If I have, if I sort of bias
my motion for after with respect to the center of mass of the robot,
then I got a pitching motion.
Then yaw is a little bit more tricky,
I basically have to keep the frequency
fixed and have a faster downstroke than an upstroke.
So, I get the sort of paddling,
I'm not doing right, like that.
I get this paddling motion with asymmetric drag.
All right. So, I can build these devices.
I told you about how we design them.
So, this is an illustration of the thorax if you will, of these devices.
This is something by a former graduate student who is trying
to inject more control degrees of freedom in the device.
So in order to do this,
he was adding in things like,
I don't remember all of the numbers here but there is, I think,
four parallel four bars,
two spherical four bars,
and two spherical five bars all within a couple of cubic millimeters.
So, this is and then you can see this in this device.
So, you get a sense of the rich topological complexity
and mechanism complexity we can achieve using these devices.
It's hard to see because thanks to James Weaver for making this image.
But you can't see the materials here.
But there is carbon fiber, and there is titanium,
and there is poly-amides,
and all host of other materials.
Okay. So, we can make these things.
Hopefully, you're convinced now that we can make these sort of complex devices,
bio-inspired devices on these scales.
The next thing that we turned to in
this project is how do we actually think about flight control for these things.
So, I haven't really told you about that yet
but we've spent quite a bit of time trying to
understand the fluid mechanics associated with flapping
wing flights, structure function relationships.
How do we understand how to design a wing?
Is an insect wing exactly what we should be doing?
There's a huge morphological diversity within insect wings.
In fact, that's how insects are classified by the wing shape.
So, I mean to some extent.
So, how do we actually think about
understanding fluid mechanics? I'm not going to tell you about that.
But we've spent a lot of time developing strategies both numerically,
analytically, and experimentally to understand that.
So, we can control wing motions.
We can control fluid forces.
Now, the question is how do we control body attitudes?
We've done this through this schematic here,
just shows the architecture that we have,
which is doing things off board.
So, having an off-board set in  motion capture cameras.
You can think about this is the same thing that is used in CGI, right?
To the mix Gollum and I'm forgetting the names from the new Star Wars movie.
But with all of them where they wear suits of little retro reflective markers,
and then move around,
and then be recreated in CGI.
So, it's the same environment,
but now it's shrunk down,
and these little markers are now on our little robots.
So, that's what it looks like in reality.
You can't really see what's going on here, but there's the robot.
If I do this now,
thinking about what control actually means for these things,
if I just plug these things in and turn them on,
this is what happens, right?
So, these are open loop flights.
This is slow down by a factor of eight.
I'm showing this to illustrate two things or three things.
One is that the open loop dynamics are very fast.
So, I'll show you this in real time in a minute.
I'll show to you now. So, this is that real time.
So, open loop dynamics are really fast, which is good.
We want to take advantage of that.
The open loop dynamics are unstable, which is also good.
Insects are the fighter jets of the animal kingdom, right?
I mean you've seen these things if you try to swat a fly, you know this.
They operates very dissimilar to a passenger jet
where in the absence of active controls
if the pilot takes his or her hand off of the stick,
it should, by virtue of positive wing dihedral,
it should remain with a stable attitude.
So, the antithesis of that are of many flying insects.
So, it's operating on
the other end of that spectrum and we want to take advantage of that.
But nonetheless, we still need to be able to stabilize this unstable system.
So, I won't get into the details of how we do this.
It dives deep into some control theory.
There's some really interesting aspects of this,
and some not so interesting aspects of this.
But it turns out using this architecture,
we can prototype whatever controller you want.
The key things here are latencies.
So, between perception information that's coming in this case from motion capture,
but we also have on-board sensors that we can put on now as well.
Keeping the latency down between that information and your actuation is key.
But if you do that well,
then you can do things like this.
Hovering is really particularly challenging because as I said before,
in the absence of active control,
this thing is just going to fly out of control.
In the absence of forward flights,
there's no hope of passive stability here.
So, you really have to be active.
That last half second there are actually just
illustrated one of the nice things about operating at these scales.
You can crush these things all you want and they're not going to break.
So, larger systems, certainly human sized vehicles,
but even these small drones and UAVs,
you even come close to a wall and they're going to shatter, right?
So, not so in these cases and this is due to the physics of scaling.
I'm happy to talk to you about that offline.
We can also get much more aggressive with these types of maneuvers.
This is something called iterative learning control
where by the fact that we can crash these things,
we don't care about crashing these things.
I'm exaggerating a little bit, but we don't really care about crashing these things.
So, we can try to do these aggressive maneuvers where this is trial eight or seven.
In the first seven or eight of these things have failed. They crash into the wall.
But you learn from understanding
the dynamics of those crashes of those failures how to actually do this well.
A little bit more recently,
we've actually taken advantages
of the relatively high payload that we have for these systems,
and develop some perching strategies that leverage
active electrode adhesives that we put on the top of
the device and allows us to go and perch on whatever we want.
So, the motivation here is simple is basically
the energetics of flight at this scale are so power hungry,
so energetically expensive that you're not going to fly around for too
long without expending your battery or whatever power source you have.
So, perching strategies make a lot of sense for any real mission.
Okay. So, I'm going to shift gears here.
So, I should say a few words about where this project is,
just in case you're curious.
You'll notice that all of these videos had
a tether and they all had external motion capture.
You can make batteries that are they can fit on board.
Just yesterday we got the control electronics
and control board that will go on board that are being integrated as we speak.
So, hopefully those challenges will be resolved,
and the tether will be cut and fully autonomous sometime in the near future.
By the way, has anybody seen Black Mirror?
So, you're probably like, ''Why the hell are you doing this?
This is crazy.'' Right. So, yeah.
These are 30 40 years away from anything remotely practical,
let alone doing harm.
Another device that is a little bit more mature but
relies on some of the same strategies that I just described is this device.
It is very similar actuation strategies to make small-legged devices.
These things have a number of nice features that we can make them fully autonomous.
They have fairly high payloads which is actually not surprising given
their biological inspiration also has very high payloads relative to their weight.
They actually turn out to be some of the fastest robots on earth,
if you normalize to body length.
They also happen to be very highly dynamic.
So, these are not particularly useful gates but
they illustrate this highly dynamic nature of these robots.
This is partially due to their scale and I'm
happy to go into that a little bit deeper offline.
I'm also not showing a result here because it's unpublished,
but we can get them climbing on walls and ceilings as well.
One of the things that we're aiming for for
these types of robots is high value asset inspection.
So, we're working with a company
that is interested in having small robots go where borescopes can't go.
Basically go and inspect things, look for cracks,
cracks in engines for example which would not require them to be taken out of service.
So, I'm going to move on to another example which is
entirely different but hopefully shares some of the same things.
In fact, I think this actually illustrates
the overall thesis that I have about
the mechanical side of artificial intelligence better than the rest,
and that's soft robots for the deep sea.
So, this story starts off with this and I want you to hear that.
I 'm not sure he's going to swim anymore.
There he goes! And it's sideways, I told you he'd swim sideways.
This is from friends at NOAA,
this is exactly, it is what it is.
So, this is a robotic arm on the ocean floor trying to do a sampling,
trying to do a collection task.
So, there is a group of scientists and
marine biologists who are very interested in both exploration,
what's in the deep sea, what are in the deepest parts of the ocean we don't know.
I could quote you statistics and stuff but I'll save that for you.
The other thing is just generally speaking there's a lot of reasons to try
to collect organisms from depths that go beyond what humans can reach,
so beyond scuba or technical diving.
So, those are things like understanding how mesopelagic organisms
are reacting to ocean acidification or warming temperatures,
and so you want to get these things and be able to sample them.
But you also want to do this gently,
not only because you don't want to mangle the things like it's happening here,
or like here, this is another example,
I believe it's a glass sponge.
We want to be able to collect this,
but with this sort of jaws of life looking thing it's impossible.
Right? Not only is there no way to get it really,
but even if you've got it,
it's biology is going to be masked by the stress that you just induced on it.
I saw these videos when I was at a meeting of the National Geographic Society,
and there was one of our now colleagues that was there,
and was trying to grab these things from
the deep ocean and it couldn't for these reasons.
So, right around that time we
were starting to work in this nascent subfield of robotics called soft robotics.
Soft robotics is just what it sounds like,
trying to make robots out of rubber.
So, there's a number of reasons you might want to do this,
if you want to make anything,
I could start off with a question to you.
If I asked you to close your eyes and think about a robot,
and setting where robots can exist, what are you thinking of?
Where are robots practical?
Sorry, factories.
So factory floors,
assembling welding doors on cars whatever.
So, that's a typical and extremely successful automation example of robotics.
But what do you not see in that in that vision?
Soft robots.
You don't see soft robots if you don't see humans, you don,t see anything soft.
You don't see anything delicate near them because they're dangerous.
In fact, you see cages around them such
that they're not going to harm anything or anyone.
So, the motivation for soft robots is kind of get away from that to make robots that are
impedance matched to natural systems to humans.
We have some efforts in wearable robotics,
there's a lot of efforts that are led at the Wyss Insitute to by
Conor Walsh in Wearable Assistive Devices.
So, that's one application,
it sort of gives you the flavor of soft robotics.
So, we were doing this a few years ago trying to figure out,
well, if we're going to make robots out of soft materials,
how do we make the core components?
So, how do we understand and how do we make sensors and actuators?
Very simple things. How do we make a motor equivalence but out of rubber?
So, this is an example where it's just in
the last tumeric balloon that's being pressurized internally,
and if you pressurize this thing it'll change it's shape.
One of the tricks that went in here is if I start to reinforce this last tumeric balloon
with an extensible fibers or
any inextensible material then I can get extension bending coupling,
extension twisting coupling, I can get all sorts of
complex motions and I can do this without control.
So, there's no control here. I just pump in pressure
and the thing deforms the way I want it to, the way I programmed it to.
So, this is again coming back to the original thesis
involving this mechanical side
of artificial intelligence. I want to get away from control.
I'll wrap control at a higher level around this,
but at the lower level I want to have things sort of figure things out for themselves.
This is just a simple example of anthropomorphic hand,
but nonetheless we show that we can create very effective devices.
So, we convinced the National Geographic Society to send us on an expedition.
In this case, it was over to the Red Sea,
it was with our collaborator who had
this remotely operated vehicle where we basically cut the hand
off of the arm that was on it and put our soft hands on it.
So, this was the first example
of this is a shameless plug back to the National Geographic Society
where that's me thanking our sponsors effectively.
What we did was,
the first example of delicate manipulation at the bottom of the ocean in this case,
this was only a couple of 100 meters or about 150 meters
below the surface where we were trying to grasp these whip corals.
But it was the first successful,
we were able to actually grab these gently
and there's a little cutter at the bottom here,
just snip them off and bring them back up to the surface.
You can imagine, go back a couple of slides,
if I have that rigid gripper system,
and I want to grab this thing and I am a couple of
100 meters even more in some of the videos I'll show you in a minute.
A couple of 100 meters below me and all I have a visual feedback from the cameras.
They're very nice cameras but all I have is basically
two dimensional visual feedback from the ROV,
and now the boat's rocking right.
So, how do I do this really tricky manipulation task?
In this case and maybe I'll play this again,
in this case it turns out to be a trivial thing in the sense
that we take advantage of this concept that I said before about bending, twisting,
coupling, and I just get close enough and power this thing and it
wraps itself up into a helix and grabs this thing.
There's other types of examples that we had,
this is more of broccoli
looking coral where we can just basically give it a nice gentle hug,
there's all sorts of features here which enhance the gentleness of this come in,
clip it, and bring it back to the surface.
So, that was a couple of years ago.
We then wanted to expand this,
and so we've basically been hitching rides on anybody that has a big boat.
A couple of times now we've been with with Bob Ballard on the Nautilus and hooked
up these soft manipulators to this case, this ROV hercules.
I think this is about 1.8 kilometers below
the surface where this is grabbing this holothurian here,
the sea cucumber where this is something which is
effectively the consistency of wet tissue paper under water.
But nonetheless, we're able to very delicately grab it, pick it up, put it back down.
We didn't bring it to the surface in this case because this was
just an exploration mission of what we actually could do.
But I take this example specifically as one of the most delicate objects I can
imagine gripping and in one of the harshest environments I could imagine doing this in.
I throw a very dumb gripper.
It's just a simple three finger thing that I just pump
sea water into and I can do this task very well.
I understand, and James you can correct me that these animals have
a defense mechanism or they invert their stomachs
as a defense mechanism if they're frightened,
as one of my students said sort of take my wallet and leave me alone kind of thing,
and this guy showed none of those.
We can also grasp.
These are things, by the way, you can kind of hear the banter of
the ROV pilots while this is happening.
A lot of times we hear like, "Oh,
we would never go after that thing with a rigid grip or it just would work."
Yeah.
Here's one example where it's not necessarily a delicate thing.
This is a crab but we can go down and grab basically whatever we want.
It's awesome.
Then, put it back down unharmed.
The last thing I want to tell you about is,
a project that we had with with Jennifer Lewis' group.
It starts with the following obvious observation which is sure,
the end effectors of those things are soft but everything from here on is rigid.
So, your rigid arm and valve manifold and pumps and ROV,
whatever is all sort of classical,
very well engineered but nonetheless is,
sort of a rigid body devices.
So, the question is, can we create robots that are entirely soft?
Where there are absolutely no rigid components.
So, that's what we set out to do and
that boiled down for us into some sort of sub-questions.
Those sub-questions were:
How do we create the core components for these things?
The core components of any robot might be,
at least on a lower level,
thinking about the mechanisms.
We have sensors, actuators, computation, and power.
So, how do we do those four things?
So, actuation, I already told you about,
we can create fluidic actuation no problem.
Sensors, I didn't tell you about but I can tell you about off line,
we can do that fairly easily as well.
But in terms of, how do we think about creating a little controller that's soft?
How do we think about having power that soft?
Certainly not traditional batteries.
So, long story short is that we leveraged chemical power for these systems.
So, the the fluidic based actuators require pressurized fluid gas or liquid.
So, what we do is, we rely on peroxide decomposition.
So, our modern propellant decomposition,
in this case hydrogen peroxide,
in the presence of a platinum catalyst.
So, it's a very energetic reaction and I can tell you
about the kinetics of this later but nonetheless,
the products of this are hot gases basically,
that are useful to power whatever fluidic actuator you want downstream.
Okay, that's great but that doesn't say any about control.
If I just sort of dump peroxide on a catalyst and then, capture that gas,
that's going to actuate me just fine but it's not
going to do anything with any sort of sequence or control.
So, the second piece of this puzzle is leveraging many decades worth of
progress in microfluidics and soft lithography to create fluidic-based control circuits.
So, it turns out, you can use microfluidic systems to
create almost any sort of copy, in a loose way,
to any electrical circuit that you might want, circuit components, resistors,
capacitors and even high order things like
digital logic and sequencers, counters, comparators, whatever.
I can do that all in fluidic systems.
This is an example of what we used which
is a very simple example of just a fluidic oscillators.
So, I pump in a constant positive pressure and the output is
basically an oscillation of pressure on multiple outputs.
So, there is the architecture that we have where we have this fuel goes through
this microfluidic logic circuits gets broken down,
past the check valve into a catalyst site that then catalyzes this reaction,
produces gas that then actuate these actuators downstream.
So, this is where some beautiful innovation from
our collaborators in the Lewis group came in.
So, this is a concept that they developed called Embedded 3D printing where you take,
what you're seeing here is a vat of
uncured elastomer and this uncured elastomer
then is being injected with a sacrificial ink.
So, there's all sorts of tricks that are associated with realogy of this,
to get these to be stable structures even though uncured.
But nonetheless, let's ignore that for a minute.
They were able to inject
this sacrificial ink wherever they want
within the sort of structure of this uncured elastomer.
This eventually forms the vasculature if you will, of this robot.
So, what happens is, once this printing process is done,
and so you're seeing the actuators and the limbs being printed now.
Once this printing process is done,
this whole thing is cured and so the elastomer solidifies then,
you still have this sacrificial ink within the vasculature.
It turns out that the silicone-based elastomers that we use are porous to water and the
Pluronic that's used as the ink for
these things will break down basically in the water and then, self-evacuate.
So, you basically have voids that are
formed more or less for free at the end of this process.
So, that's the vasculature,
that's the main, sort of internal structure of this device,
and they also figured out ways to print
platinum-laden inks as well to do the catalyst site as well.
Then, the last step which you
didn't quite see but it sort of illustrated on the top here is,
prior to all of this we use
soft lithography techniques to create this microfluidic control system,
plant that in the uncured elastomer matrix and then,
prints into that device as well.
So, what that gives you at the end is this,
which we call the Octobot,
and also this is a bit metaphorical.
I would say almost every single talk I've seen by somebody that mentions
the word soft robotics shows an octopus as inspiration which makes sense.
So, that was our inspiration I guess in some ways as well.
This is a robot now and I'm going to use
quotes purposely and you can see the components of this device,
sort of in florescence here,
where you have your fluidic control system,
a fluid reservoir, catalyst sites.
You see all of this is a vasculature that make up the actuation sites.
Okay, so how does this work? So, here's the schematic
again of this thing in operation and here's what actually happens.
So, I inject a fuel being done on the bottom left here,
on the bottom two videos and the pressure from the fuel,
sort of expanding the elastomeric reservoir pushes the fuel through the control system.
Then like I said, it gets broken down at the catalyst site,
it gets alternated between catalyst sites and then,
downstream then gets alternated between actuation sites.
So, at the end of the day, this fantastic robot just basically just does this.
Okay. So, that I mean we're very proud of this. We're very excited by this.
This I think speaks very clearly to this notion of trying to do
as much of the sensing actuation control power,
whatever in hardware, prior to actually wrapping a controller around it.
It is the first, entirely soft robot if you will again in quotes.
So, we were happy about this and this got published in Nature a couple of years ago.
But really it's more about being provocative.
I think that there's a really,
I want to end with this sort of notion.
Who's familiar with this?
This is called an automata,
which was made back in the 1700's unsurprisingly by Swiss watchmakers.
It's a piece of art which is,
if you sort of open up and look under the hood,
it's a series of gears and cans and levers which are all connected to this mechanism,
which allows this boy to write out complex passages of text. Is this a robot?
Is it programmable?
Is it programmable? No. It's programmable design time but not re-programmable, certainly.
So, now I'm seeing you're shaking your heads.
No. No, it's not really a robot, right?
What if I were to go and buy
a Baxter and put a pen in its hands and do all the path planning
control for the exact same passage of text and have
it react to the page and maybe have some vision system.
Is that a robot? There's no wrong answer here.
But yeah, I mean yeah, that's a robot, right?
So, I guess the question I'm trying to get at is,
at what point do we take this very simple concept that we had,
this trivial controller which is just sort of making this oscillation happen.
Many groups have done far,
far more complicated fluidic networks.
Thousands and thousands of valves which
you can equate a valve to a transistor in a very loose way.
So, we can get much more complex behaviors if you will out
of these types of systems and I'm not going to pretend to answer this question.
This is the subject, I think of some of the philosophy I work now.
But, at what point do we stop with this path of
trying to increase the mechanical complexity and sort of,
at the potential expense of performance or not,
and where do we sort of bring in decades worth of
classical electrical controllers and AI that are very common in robotics?
So, that's where I want to stop.
We worked on a bunch of other topics that I'm sort of
illustrating here related to artificial muscles,
bio-inspired robots, ultra-fast motion.
This is the sensors that I was alluding to before.
We're working on projects where we're taking some of
these micro fabrication techniques to make small scale surgical tools,
endoscopy tools that have just finished animal trials.
We can make self-holding robots,
3D-printer robots that jump.
This is also a jeans and a whole host of other things that I'm happy
to tell you more about if you want to buy me a drink next door.
I'll stick around. Otherwise, I'm very
grateful for your attention, for your participation.
Thank you again for the invitation.